[Música]
Hola bienvenidos al debate de France 24
soy Santiago López González en una
decisión histórica a la corte de
constitucional de Colombia votó a favor
de despenalizar la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo hasta la semana
24 de gestación durante meses el tema
fue dilatado por las autoridades o por
complicaciones administrativas también
por reclamos de diferentes
organizaciones contrarias a esta medida
y también la división que esto estaba
comenzando a generar en la sociedad
colombiana entre otros temas que llevan
a este tipo de decisiones en sociedades
democráticas como la que Colombia quiere
mostrarse ante el mundo finalmente la
corte aprobó esta decisión por 5 votos a
favor y cuatro en contra el aborto no
dejará de ser un delito en el marco del
Código Penal lo que cambia es que la ley
ahora ampara a las mujeres o niñas
gestantes con 24 semanas o 6 meses para
que decidan poner fin a su embarazo
de la sociedad colombiana celebraron
esta medida mientras que otros la
criticaron con fuertes argumentos lo que
sí es cierto es que Colombia entra en
una reducida lista de países que
permiten la interrupción del embarazo
veamos entonces en el continente
americano Cómo está la situación vemos
en color verde a países como Uruguay
Argentina Colombia Guyana la Guyana
Francesa que es un departamento de
ultramar francés Cuba Estados Unidos y
Canadá en donde se permite la
interrupción del embarazo a petición de
la persona con algunas limitantes en
torno al tiempo de gestación caso
Colombia como les decía que tienen hasta
24 semanas en color amarillo tenemos a
Bolivia Perú a Ecuador y a Costa Rica
que permiten la interrupción para
preservar la salud de la madre en color
anaranjado tenemos a Brasil a Paraguay
chile Venezuela Panamá Guatemala y
México que lo permite para salvar la
vida de la mujer en azul tenemos a
Belice en América que permite la
interrupción con amplios motivos
sociales y económicos
finalmente en rojo tenemos a surinam
Nicaragua Honduras El Salvador República
Dominicana Haití y Jamaica dónde es
totalmente prohibido
Colombia es el único país de la región
que permite la interrupción hasta la
semana 24 de gestación en otros países
la normativa cambia por ejemplo en
Argentina es hasta la semana 14 Colombia
es un país que presenta también altas
tasas de embarazo adolescente el abuso
sexual ha sido un arma de guerra en las
más de cinco décadas de conflicto que ha
tenido este país sudamericano o 50 años
de conflicto armado además hablar de
sexo en las escuelas tiene todavía
ciertos límites en cierta forman algunas
zonas Rurales sigue siendo un tabú en la
sociedad y la iglesia por supuesto juega
un papel muy importante en la sociedad
colombiana son realidades que pueden ser
complicadas a la hora de tomar estas
decisiones pero que son compartidas
también con muchos otros países de
América Latina por lo que el caso
colombiano puede servir de ejemplo para
otras naciones de la región de acuerdo
con cifras del 2020 unas 4268 Menores en
Colombia con edades entre los si los 14
años fueron madres lo que evidencia está
alta incidencia del embarazo en menores
de edad de otra parte pues la pregunta
que surge es A qué se enfrentan entonces
las mujeres colombianas que interrumpían
su embarazo desde el 2008 unas 400
mujeres por año fueron criminalizadas o
condenadas por interrumpir sus embarazos
ella se enfrentan entonces apenas
comprendidas entre los 16 y los 54 meses
las más perseguidas por supuesto pues
son las menores de edad la mayoría de
ellas en zonas Rurales o en el campo
colombiano
en el contexto internacional Colombia Se
suma así como lo decía una reducida
lista solamente 47 países antes
penalizado el aborto en las últimas
décadas
Qué significa está despenalización del
aborto para las colombianas para las
mujeres colombianas para la sociedad de
este país que tiene muchos tintes
conservadores que controversia ha traído
este debate para y esta aprobación por
parte de la corte constitucional Y qué
trámite le resta entonces de acuerdo a
las leyes colombianas para que sea
efectivo vamos a analizar este tema Oye
aquí en el debate de France 24 y para
analizarlo hemos invitado a Cristina
Rosero Arteaga ella asesora legal del
centro de derecho reproductivo se
encuentra en la ciudad de Bogotá la
capital colombiana también hemos
invitado a juliet Gómez Bernal ella es
abogada y activista ustedes nuestros
televidentes también pueden participar
en este debate con sus comentarios y sus
preguntas lo pueden hacer A través de
las redes sociales nos encuentran como
ya lo saben en Facebook en Instagram y
en Twitter estamos como arroba France
24_s@santilólogo que es mi cuenta
personal les recuerdo nuestra etiqueta
es numeral el debate f24 esperamos todos
sus comentarios y sus preguntas y quiero
comenzar Entonces primero conociendo las
opiniones de nuestras invitadas comienzo
por Cristina allí en la ciudad de Bogotá
conociendo
impresiones y su postura En cuanto está
toma de decisión por parte de la corte
constitucional colombiana y lo que
significa esto para la sociedad y para
las colombianas
Gracias por esta invitación
que fue presentada en septiembre del
2020 para nosotras fue un fallo que sin
duda constituyó un avance histórico para
los derechos de las mujeres en el país y
que sin duda puede contribuir de manera
muy importante a eliminar las muertes
asociadas a los abortos realizados en
condiciones inseguras y también a la
criminalización contra las mujeres más
vulnerables de la sociedad colombiana
y cuál es su opinión sobre estas
decisión de la corte constitucional y lo
que Ah Esto entonces para la sociedad
colombiana Cuál es su impresión
Bueno creo que hemos tenemos problemas
con el audio de juliet sigue con
nosotros no me confirma que tenemos en
la conexión juliet se mantiene entonces
con nosotros Cristina también desde la
ciudad de Bogotá pasó preguntarles Qué
puede suceder entonces con las mujeres
que ya en el pasado fueron sentenciadas
o tuvieron que rendir cuentas ante la
justicia colombiana
por haber interrumpido sus embarazos en
qué
postura o en qué parte de la
jurisprudencia colombiana quedan ellas
después de esta decisión de la corte
Cristina
bueno la ley penal establece unos
principios de favorabilidad según los
cuales si existe un cambio en la Norma
que establece que lo que antes fue
considerado un delito ya no lo es
eventualmente las personas que fueron
condenadas por lo que entonces se
consideraba como tal fueron solicitar
una revisión de su sentencia y también
hay en los casos en los que se
encuentren aún en una investigación se
pueda también solicitar el cierre del
caso por aticicidad entonces dentro de
las causales de revisiones de sentencias
en el código penal si esta establecido
el hecho de que haya una nueva Norma que
elimine esta criminalización lo cual
aplicaría para todos los abortos
realizados en los casos de menos de 24
semanas y eh para las mujeres que se
encuentran actualmente en una
investigación eventualmente también
pueden solicitar la revisión y el cierre
de estas investigaciones que están
actualmente presentándose de modo que ya
está criminalización no debería estar
aplicando en este caso ya que
Igor esta decisión de la corte
colombiana de la corte constitucional
qué otra alternativa ven ustedes para
estas personas que ya fueron juzgadas
que ya están cumpliendo sus penas por
haber interrumpido sus embarazos Qué
opinión tiene para usted este tipo de
decisión
juliet continuó con usted le preguntó
precisamente por estos datos que usted
pone aquí sobre la mesa que me parece
bien poner aquí a disposición del debate
Esto entonces qué nos quiere decir esto
evidencia ese lado oscuro que tiene
la realización de abortos clandestinos
que claro como era una práctica que no
era legal en el país A menos que
tuvieran tres causas en muy puntuales
como lo estima la Constitución
colombiana la ley colombiana eh era un
hecho
ilegal esto no evidencia precisamente
esa industria oscura eh todo esa todo lo
que hay debajo de cuerda de esta
industria en donde mueren mujeres donde
se vuelve un negocio y donde claramente
pues las cifras oficiales no cuadran
con lo que se percibe en el día a día
Claro que sí es que es totalmente cierto
de verdad hay una industria detrás del
aborto pero no es tanto como la ven o
como nos la quieren hacer creer a los
colombianos e incluso como se presenta
de manera internacional
va a ser una realidad que va a mudar en
mujeres que van a pensar que esto lo
pueden tomar como método anticonceptivo
nuestra otra invitada su opinión sobre
estas declaraciones lo que dice el punto
de vista de Julia
Muchas gracias Bueno la primera
aclaración sobre los datos frente a la
criminalización de las mujeres y cuáles
son las condenas contra ellas es una
aclaración sencilla si Únicamente se
están observando los datos de inpec pues
tenemos un Universo de datos incompleto
nuestras cifras están basadas en las
fiscalía general de la nación que es la
entidad que en Colombia realiza todas
las investigaciones penales y que por lo
tanto tiene un conocimiento de Cuántos
procesos se encuentran abiertos desde la
denuncia hasta la condena del caso en el
caso del inpec Únicamente se contarían
con los casos en los cuales se está
pagando con una condena intramural eh
dado que el delito de aborto tiene una
condena menor a los 4 años en muchos
casos se puede dar como un delito
descarcelable sin embargo esto no
significa que las mujeres no hayan
recibido una condena penal y no puedan
estar privadas de la libertad por
ejemplo eventualmente podrían estar
cumpliendo un beneficio de casa por
cárcel que igual implica
de su libertad y en otros casos Incluso
si no se cumple con una restricción de
la libertad las mujeres condenadas
tienen este tema en sus antecedentes
penales o pueden estar cumpliendo otros
tipos de sanciones que de todas maneras
van a crearles una serie de Barreras por
ejemplo para después conseguir trabajo o
que van a tener que enfrentar Barrera su
estigma como resultado de ser una
persona que fue condenada por el delito
del aborto entonces puede ser que no
todas las mujeres se encuentren en la
cárcel como consecuencia de ser
condenadas por este delito Pero por
supuesto Eso sí tiene unas graves
consecuencias sobre su vida ahora bien
frente al tema de las cifras de cómo se
presentan los abortos dentro o fuera de
las clínicas clandestinas hay unos datos
que son muy importantes la experiencia a
nivel mundial eh nosotros la tenemos
revisada Porque se entrega derecho
reproductivo realiza una una peo de las
leyes de aborto a nivel mundial y cómo
vas implementación Y lo que muestran las
cifras en los hundimos 25 años es un
camino muy claro hacia la penalización
cada vez más esto porque es cada vez más
evidente que cuando el delito de aborto
se encuentra de manera muy restrictiva
en la legislación esto empuja a las
mujeres a la clandestinidad y se
disparan las muertes asociadas a los
abortos realizados en condiciones
inseguras por el contrario cuando se dan
las legalizaciones esto no implica un
incremento exponencial de las
interrupciones del embarazo simplemente
las interrupciones que se realizaban por
fuera del servicio de salud se realizan
ahora en condiciones seguras y esto
previene una serie de daños a la salud y
la vida de las mujeres por lo tanto no
significa que va a haber un incremento
en los embarazos Perdón en las en los
abortos sino por el contrario que esto
se van a realizar en unas condiciones
distintas las comparaciones que se ha
realizado en diferentes
países de la región y en general del
mundo muestran que la legalización es la
forma más efectiva de acabar con las
clínicas clandestinas
Cristina
Quiero preguntarle a Cristina por casos
de éxito en la región vemos Que Colombia
ha sonado mucho nivel internacional por
dar estas 24 semanas para la toma de
decisión por parte de las gestantes Qué
hay de los otros países de la región que
yo mencionaba al inicio del programa
argentino Uruguay en cierta forma México
bueno Estados Unidos y Canadá Cuál ha
sido la experiencia que han tenido estos
países que le puede servir de elección a
Colombia
sin duda la experiencia más
significativa es que en general estos
países han mostrado una disminución
considerable de las muertes asociadas a
los abortos realizados en condiciones
inseguras al igual que una menor
criminalización de las mujeres más
vulnerables por cuenta de este delito
cuando el delito se empieza a hacer más
limitado en la legislación se abre un
campo más fácil para que las mujeres
puedan acudir a los servicios de salud
sin miedo a ser denunciados por sus
propios médicos y a su vez para que los
médicos puedan proveer información y
acceso a los servicios Sin temor a ser
criminalizados y esto es redonda en la
capacidad de mejores personas que puedan
tener mayor información y mayores
posibilidades de tomar estas decisiones
de manera libre informada eh Hay
solamente un ejemplo que iría mucho más
avanzado que Colombia ahora en la región
que sería Canadá que únicamente lo
regula por fuera del derecho penal y que
solamente incluye una regulación desde
el sistema de salud y que ha mostrado
ser la más exitosa para prevenir muertes
maternas por aborto sin y para facilitar
las decisiones autónomas de las personas
en los países donde hay una prohibición
total caso El Salvador Honduras o
Nicaragua o incluso algunas naciones del
Caribe se puede hablar de algunos casos
de éxito donde está normativa haya
funcionado para reducir la cantidad de
muertes de mujeres que han tenido que
practicarse el aborto en condiciones
clandestinas o de formas no aptas para
este tipo de Procedimientos
es usted partidaridad de esta opción o
de una opción de una que se pueda
practicar la interrupción con ciertas
condiciones como venía presentando
Colombia desde hace algunos años con
tres casos puntuales
como ha pasado en Argentina como ha
pasado
no implica que la práctica del mismo
vaya a ser segura tenemos el caso de
María que falleció una activista Pro
aborto Argentina
en la línea para preguntarle y hacer la
ronda la inversa Este es un tema que va
ligado con muchas aristas es un tema muy
va a tratar aquí abarcar la mayor
cantidad de temas posibles si esto va
ligado eh una de estas aristas puede ser
el embarazo adolescente el embarazo de
las menores de edad yo daba las cifras
al inicio del programa Colombia es un
país con cifras muy altas con respecto a
la región en qué otras opciones entonces
que no sean una suspensión del embarazo
ya usted me corregía en el término no es
una interrupción es simplemente abortar
y punto como lo dice ustedes de su punto
de vista pueden tener estas jóvenes
entre los 10 y los 14 años que han sido
abusadas o que han tenido relaciones
sexuales a temprana edad y que han
quedado en embarazo qué otras opciones
se les puede dar entonces
bueno Muchas gracias por por el cambio
del término de interrupción a suspensión
Se lo agradezco mucho es verdad Colombia
tiene una taza bastante alta lo cual es
muy triste sin embargo no considero la
verdad que el aborto sea la solución
Comparto el término de educación sexual
en Colombia triste
a valorar el cuerpo a cuidar el cuerpo y
a Resaltar y rescatar la importancia y
el valor de la sexualidad lo que se hace
es promover una percepción
infantil recuerdo yo si es cierto no soy
joven tampoco soy tan vieja que antes a
nosotros en lugar de darnos un
preservativo o enseñarnos a consumir
anticonceptivos que realmente lo que
hacen es afectar la salud de la mujer
precisamente nos enseñaban valores
porque acá es algo que generalmente y
muy tristemente pasa se piensa que los
valores es únicamente la parte de la
educación religiosa no
el hecho de que un ser humano sea
concebido de una manera inesperada y de
una manera violenta no le resta dignidad
al ser humano y eso acá lo podemos ver
desde tratados internacionales
y Cristina su opinión sobre este tema
Las opciones que se le puede dar a las
menores de edad que pueden tener
diferentes escenarios han tenido ya lo
decíamos relaciones sexuales a temprana
edad o son Víctimas de abuso una
realidad que es muy común en Colombia un
país que tiene un conflicto social muy
complejo de entender y qué otras
opciones se les puede dar cuando también
la educación sexual hablar de sexualidad
en un aula de clase en cierta forma
sigue siendo un tabú
Bueno un primer punto que es muy
importante aclarar es que siempre el
aborto Incluso si se encuentra
legalizado en ningún caso es una
obligación lo que significa que con esta
decisión la corte simplemente ampliado
el abanico de opciones que tienen las
niñas adolescentes y mujeres y personas
con capacidad de gestar de tomar ese
tipo de decisiones pero que en ningún
momento se implica por ejemplo la
obligación de interrumpir un embarazo de
darle terminación a este embarazo por
esta razón las opciones que se están
presentando para las niñas y las
adolescentes son exactamente las mismas
que hemos venido promoviendo desde el
movimiento de derechos sexuales y
reproductivos Y esto es todas aquellas
opciones que permitan el ejercicio de
autonomía reproductiva de su manera
libre que significa esto que si
eventualmente las niñas adolescentes
las condiciones adecuadas para que
puedan ejercer esa maternidad pero que
si deciden terminar con ese embarazo a
través un procedimiento de aborto
también se les garantizan unas
condiciones seguras sin estigma y con
calidad esto Qué significa
para dar todo ese soporte ese apoyo en
este momento a las jóvenes y a las
mujeres colombianas
y lo que precisamente ocurría por la
criminalización es que existen una serie
de estigmas prejuicios alrededor de la
interrupción del embarazo que hacían que
creaban unos obstáculos en la práctica y
hacían difícil este acceso sin embargo
creemos que esta decisión de ayer abre
la posibilidad de tener una base
normativa mucho más amplia y por
supuesto estaremos muy atentas a que el
uso de los protocolos y de La regulación
que ya existe en salud se extienda a las
24 horas sin exigir ningún tipo de
requisito y con un sistema de vigilancia
y control que permita evitar que estas
barreras se sigan presentando
hay una cantidad muy grande de abortos
que están quedando por fuera de las
cifras oficiales porque ocurren de forma
clandestina quizás se presentan una
especie de aumento entre comillas del
número de abortos que ocurren es porque
esta vez ocurren dentro del sistema de
salud y Esta vez sí pueden
contabilizarse por lo tanto lo que
aparenta ser un incremento de los
abortos en realidad es una
transformación de abortos que antes
ocurrían por fuera del sistema de salud
y que no podían contabilizarse a cifras
que ya se pueden establecer de la norma
oficial porque esta vez ocurren de
manera legal dentro del sistema ha
reducido en la cifras es el número de
mujeres que fallecen en estos
procedimientos así lo demuestran las
cifras oficiales la República Oriental
ya le doy la palabra juliet quiero
hacerle la última pregunta a Cristina
sobre este máximo de 24 semanas ya va
mucho la atención por parte de la
comunidad internacional que el gobierno
en las autoridades hayan dado estos 6
meses por qué Colombia da hasta 6
semanas estás 24 semanas que son 6 meses
si lo comparamos con otros países como
por ejemplo Argentina que solamente da
14 que igual es un tiempo prudencial
introducida
considere un plazo muy amplio para
facilitar el acceso
la comunicación con usted para las
personas que viven fuera de las
fronteras colombianas que no tienen muy
claro el marco legal de este país que
pasa entonces con las mujeres que se
realizan procedimientos después de las
24 semanas esto a partir de ahí sí es
considerado Entonces como un delito y
vuelve otra vez a poner a las mujeres eh
dentro de la óptica
ante la justicia
Bueno la verdad es muy triste y es que
la situación realmente sigue Exactamente
igual la corte pensaba que
íbamos de una u otra manera a creer que
era un avance o a creer que esto era
algo que iba a facilitarle las cosas al
movimiento
para que la salud mental de la mujer
Perdón la salud mental de la mujer sigue
siendo la causa más utilizada y en esto
Me atrevo a utilizar con el dolor del
alma el caso Juan Sebastián un niño que
hace 2 años Fue asesinado en el vientre
de su madre teniendo 7 meses y medio de
gestación bajo la causal de Salud Mental
que implica esto una de las causales que
tiene que llevarse un estudio médico
a terminar la vida de su hijo en el
viento
para terminar el programa quiero cerrar
y llegar a las conclusiones Cristina que
le resta entonces a esta decisión de la
corte constitucional que le resta
entonces a Colombia a la sociedad de
este país para poner en marcha está
decisión tomada por las autoridades
[Música]
o algún tipo de Norma adicional que
permita su aplicación por lo tanto su
aplicación se debe dar de forma
inmediata como movimiento vamos a estar
trabajando muy fuertemente en la
implementación adecuada de esta
sentencia Para que no haya mujeres que
mueran por abortos inseguros en Colombia
y que todas las mujeres puedan tomar
estas decisiones de manera libre
informada sabemos que este camino tiene
unos retos y hacemos un llamado a que el
estado colombiano acompañe este proceso
haciendo cumplir lo que ahora ya es un
reconocimiento realizado judicialmente
después de esta decisión tomada por las
autoridades en Colombia
porque sabemos la realidad de las
mujeres que se practican del aborto no
solamente a nivel de salud física sino
también Salud Mental y mi conclusión
les agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros en el programa un tema muy
extenso con muchas aristas que trato de
tomar con el mayor respeto posible por
mi posición como hombre No estoy en la
posición en la que ustedes las mujeres
pueden enfrentarse a este tipo de
situaciones y sobre todo con un
escenario tan complejo a nivel social
como lo tiene un país como Colombia
después de 50 años de conflicto interno
el es muy particular y sin duda alguna
servirá de referencia para muchos temas
relacionados con la despenalización del
aborto para otras naciones que las están
o lo están estudiando Muchas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros Gracias a
ustedes por la sintonía y Pueden seguir
dejando los comentarios a través de las
redes sociales sigan con nosotros
[Música]